simplifying it and then taking immediate
action to me are the exact things people
need to be obsessively focused with
right now because right now like first
and foremost if you're in a dire
situation take care of your basic needs
men like don't worry about launching the
next Facebook like make sure that you've
got a roof over your head that you can
put food on the table right and that's
where a lot of people are gonna crash
and burn is yo Maslow's hierarchy of
needs has stood the test of time for a
reason like there are just certain
things safety security like get those
taken care of and you may have to do a
job that you didn't want to do or you
may have to call people up and banging
the phones if you're trying if you've
got a product that really has value like
you don't know how to get it out like
you've got to think like a direct
marketer and this is like where I think
my own story confuses people because
like I'm so intense and you know I've
got like that raw raw spirit but the
reality is I'm not to burn the ships at
the shore guy like I'm a yo keep your
day job man like when we launched Quest
we had a software company so during the
day I was running a software company and
nights and weekends I was making protein
bars because I wanted to see if this
would work like you're saying make sure
there's an audience before you go like
we didn't get a warehouse and start
buying equipment until we were selling
protein bars I don't even think we
bought the equipment until we were
already profitable so we were making the
bars by hand which was pure insanity
making the bars by hand ourselves nights
and weekends to make sure that there was
something real there so what advice do
you have for somebody who's like yo I
just lost my job and I feel totally out
of control what can they do as a
solopreneur
to get like that first audience to get
that first sale yeah and I want to first
off agree with you people who message me
all the time like I get a great book I'm
gonna quit my job and do this thing I'm
like no like no don't quit your job and
do the thing like keep your job because
you know as well as I do that like when
you have that like the in certainty and
like it makes the pressure so much
higher and it makes it so much harder to
like get creative and get figure things
out when when those needs are met and
well it's so much easier to go figure
things out but someone like it's funny
because I've had conversation with some
close friends who've lost their jobs who
are freaking out right now and and I and
I tried to explain it on Mike you have
to understand that like
the money didn't just disappear right
like we're like this great wealth
transfer things are shifting around like
I don't know if you know Perry Belcher
but he's one of my friends who own
survival live.com and he look at
survival life in the last 30 days has
made more money than last like 10 years
combined right like money is shifting
over there you look at you know like
it's not that it's disappeared like
people [ __ ] my there's not going to the
movie theaters and the restaurants
they're spending in other places and
like it's understanding that and so if
your whole world just got pulled away
from you it's not that the money just
just evaporate it just got transferred
somewhere
so the first amputee was looking like
you where like where is this getting
translate what are the companies and the
businesses that are making more money
right now like they can't handle it that
they're looking for more help because
because man awesome because of this new
circumstances everything is just just
growing like crazy so that's the first
thing second thing I look at is like
what is the skill set that is the most
valuable inside of a company and I've
got a friend who's a dentist I tease
them all time because you know most
dentists like there's a dentist they
like that's the most important person in
the business or I'm the person who who
does the thing on people's teeth and I
had this whole conversation I'm like
you're not the most important person in
your business yeah I'm not me they can't
clean teeth I was like I was like the
most important person in your business
is the person who can get customers to
come in the front door because that
person can't bring customers to the
front door you have no teeth to clean
therefore your skill set is useless I
make the most valuable person any
company is the person who we call Maury
makers who can make it rain who can
bring people in and it's like that's
what it comes down to like this book
traffic secrets it's like the person you
can drive traffic isn't bring the
customers in it becomes the most
valuable person in any company I have
friends who are so good at driving
traffic that they literally will find a
company that's struggling or maybe on
the downside they'll come in and say hey
look I can bring you the thing that
you're missing it's the holy grail for
your business in all businesses its
customers and I can bring you as many as
you want as often as you want the only
thing is like I don't work for money I
work for equity so if you want me to do
this I want 30% your company and people
are like just handing them the come back
here you go because you can bring you
can make it rain you can bring me
customers you can bring leads and so
like I start shifting like if I gotta
figure out a skill set in this market
it's like the most valuable thing I can
learn is how do I make it rain for a
company and then I can go plug in the
companies I like find a cut like
whatever that is but now you're so
valuable they're like when when you know
things start going down like I figured
like the dental office that through the
two last people in standing is the
dentist and dude who brings in customers
the receptionist the fire that the the
girl who does your teeth like all that
stuff gone except for the person reads a
customer in and the person doing the
actual fulfillment of the service and so
like it makes you so valuable I think
that I'd be aligning with that figuring
out that the markets the industries the
businesses that are like booming right
now and how can I go plug into those and
become the Rainmaker because then you
can write your own paycheck from this
point forward and that's that's really
the stability I think that all of us
want is to be able to have that and if
you have a skill set like that you
become invaluable when people say
they're trading time for money I told
you I don't really like that phrase
because it's usually used kind of
condescending how you trade time for
money also pedestrian but I think
actually most people can have a good job
and if you really get focused on it you
can earn a lot the challenge is that
even if you are working at a
nine-to-five job you still have to think
about building an asset because your job
could be taken away you could be fired
you could be laid off
you could go on disability or a global
pandemic could happen whatever the case
suddenly that entire single source of
income could go away so what do you do
if you are working at a nine-to-five job
and you want to build an asset an asset
is something that can produce income
even as you sleep an asset does not need
the same amount of work as as a
nine-to-five job an asset can be
incredibly powerful so what are some
examples of assets of course there's
writing a book there's building a
program a video course all that stuff
but the most common asset in the world
is a portfolio investing in the market
so before I ever had a business I was
investing in the market I built up a
portfolio and that was my asset and that
asset has grown and I believe that the
vast majority of people should start
there as their primary asset it's easy
it's low-cost it's effectively as
automated as you can possibly hope for
said to be okay then I started my
business and I started creating lots of
assets so programs a book etc I didn't
think of them like that I was like I got
to write this book so people stop asking
me about IRAs here you go but it turned
out in retrospect this book is an asset
and even as we speak people are buying
it on Kindle and physical books etc
they're buying into Indy bookstores are
checking out the library and my
publisher will get a check and they will
write me a check every quarter or so
that's an asset I wrote emails that have
generated hundreds of thousands of
dollars that's an asset
I wrote blog posts and even my team
worked on blog posts that bring in
people to our site that then turning to
customers that's an asset as well so you
can start to see wow there's a lot of
possibility around here to create an
asset an asset is taking what's in your
head maybe as a consultant or a
nine-to-five employee and packaging it
up documenting it and then making it
available for other people to access
incredibly simple on paper incredibly
profound because this asset doesn't
sleep this asset can be automatically
sold and used and that is how you can
start to really scale both your reach
and also your income we're all in an
unprecedented time right now and I'm
actually very lucky though to be working
in the food industry and so as a food
blogger a lot of people are turning to
food for comfort or you know all the
reasons so for me I've had record number
of pageviews record number of profile
visits record number of people like
remaking my recipes yet my struggle
right now is how do I get brands to
actually want to do sponsored work
because all of a sudden March 10th March
11 like just came screeching to a halt
like nobody wants to do that anymore we
don't food companies are tightening up
you know you know yesterday one of our
clients emailed us and said we're we're
not paying you this is seven figures and
you're getting fired and we might be
going back grouped you don't get that
you don't get to effect the other side
what you do right now is a hopefully
you've either saved or
you're humble enough to go backwards
this is for everybody be you go ham on
producing as much content doing as many
lives going across every platform even
trying to even waiting to do tick-tock
you've been waiting to do Twitter you do
all that now you build up so in 180 days
when she truly back to normal you're
getting that this is chess right now not
checkers it's not direct it's macro so
go hey I'm like all in like so many
people are dwelling I've heard from a
thousand of you already yeah like Gary
I'm crushing but all my money's gone
because the brands aren't sponsoring I'm
like uh-huh I'm like remember when I
told you if there was a recession like
influencers wouldn't be as fun anymore
yes good news this a fake recession aka
it doesn't have the underlining
principles to be something super long
it's likely we'll get back to normal
somewhere here later I mean the biggest
the biggest elephant in the room is if
this reinter like some experts are
saying then you're starting to get into
some but but if not then you know we're
gonna be back to normal somewhere in the
next 90 120 160 180 days I think you
need to build build build big bill and
then take the opportunities when they
come so for those of you sitting at home
right now you can either be the best
opportunity or the worst of times I've
been broke many times in my life and I
can talk about being homeless no money
alone for two weeks on a week on two
dollars and she learnt to eat pizza or
tacos or something but it was all
growing experiences
so being an entrepreneur is risky you
fail a lot and all that it's like a baby
falling down eventually I started to
walk and then once the baby starts to
walk
I want a bicycle a car than a fighter
jet you know that's that's evolution as
transformation so really that's really
what we stand for it rich debt it's not
about job security or working at a job
you hate but it's really being
challenged enjoying it making mistakes
now the big thing is who our friends are
our friends our advisors my accountants
my attorney my bankers and all this we
have different friends
best friends my account not my best
about but you know closest advisor is my
account because always taxes then
customized yes Tom we all right well tax
free well and there's Garret something's
my corporate counsel I don't want to
break the law because the laws are
different tax laws are different you
know employees pay about 40% in taxed
passes play about sixty percent in tax
big business guys pay about twenty
percent tax and ice paid zero I don't
want to break the law because I don't
want to go to jail and tap dance and be
somebody's boyfriend you know I don't
want to break the law it's a lot of the
things I do are different than what an
employee in a self-employed person and
do so you gotta have a great attorney
also I have a bookkeeper a real
bookkeeper when I meet an S like at this
small and smart but I mean and asked
that say my husband does my boss or my
wife does my books I'm out
because the numbers - probably
inaccurate I've got to have accurate
numbers and what those accurate numbers
I can give them to my accountants and my
attorneys see what that numbers you get
bad bad results so it's all of those
things that are different
it's not easy and the reason I'm happy
you guys are listening right now is
because through the magic of YouTube
social media and all that we can bring
to you the differences and because it's
up to you you know it's what you put in
your head it's who your friends are what
you think all this stuff makes a
difference eventually so for most people
they're gonna make more money because
the government that's gonna pay them
more to stay at home that's socialist
mmt modern money theory theory that's
socialist that's Bernie Sanders that's
fine but I don't want that for me
personally so the best thing about it is
is I don't have to depend upon Wall
Street for my asset I can make my own I
make my own ass is like a book and I
write a book let's say I just wrote this
book here this book is sold to 50
publishers throughout the world and they
pay us let's say ten thousand dollars
for the rights to publish my book and
they pay for the publisher they pay for
the printing they just send me the check
that's called cash flow
with that check I buy a real estate side
out to pay taxes that's the gate I had a
hard time staying disciplined in my days
like so many people do my mind and my
actions and so I have this philosophy
that button control the first 30 minutes
of my day and the last 30 minutes of my
day the probability at least of having
some measure of control over the rest of
it is increased so the first 30 minutes
of every day I get up and have a very
routine process I go through but one of
the processes both in the beginning of
the day in the end is I ask myself a
series of questions what am I most
grateful for in my life right now coz
the quality the question changes the
quality of your life and you're thinking
what am i most grateful for whom I'm
most grateful for who loves me who do I
love what am I most proud of right now
what am i most looking forward to in my
life and I do that at the beginning of
my day at the end of my day what did I
accomplish today what did I learn today
what am i grateful for who do I love who
loves me and those questions they may
seem hokey but I've been doing them for
25 years almost now and they control
what I see in my life because there's a
part a brain called the reticular
activating system and this is the part
of your brain the kind of filters our
anything is not important to you and
result is in what is important to you
it's almost like the matrix so for
example we've all experienced this we
have bought a new car like a you know a
blue Blastoise or a blue Honda all the
sudden you see blue Honda's everywhere
don't be there in the parking lot there
are three lanes over on the other side
of the road also you see them everywhere
why they were always there but now
they're filtered into your awareness and
you see them everywhere we all know what
that's like well what if the blue
Honda's of your life or what you're
grateful for what you're proud of what
you're excited about
what you're achieving and by asking
these questions they become important to
your reticular activating system and
believe it or not you begin to see feel
and hear things that were always there
that you would miss before just like
that Bluemont it's a powerful thing we
do with our minds if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation
check out the video right there next to
me I hope you find it valuable
continue to believe and
super apparent what was going to be
happening in terms of the economic
shakedown